vieles spricht dafür dass es den
rätselhaften willing nemesis tatsächlich
die bisher war der stern der unsere
sonne begleiten wollen nur eine
hypothese durch neueste untersuchung zur
sternentstehung wurde diese allerdings
jetzt bestätigt und das würde nichts
gutes bedeuten dann würde nämlich stimmt
dass ich der stern etwa alle 26
millionen jahre unserem sonnensystem
nähert und ein riesiges gestein
bombardement verursachte würden dann so
viele einschläge sein dass es ein
massenaussterben auslösen würde gibt es
also nehmen sie es wirklich und steht
uns wieder ein massenaussterben bevor
sie zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
das szenario wäre ein wirklich
unangenehmes denn selbst wenn wir in der
lage wären asteroiden kometen im anflug
zu zerstören
dieses gestein bombardement wäre
dramatisch tausende objekte würden sich
nämlich dann aus der auktion wolke lösen
und ins innere des sonnensystems zu uns
liegen hunderte davon würden auf der
erde einschlagen aber welcher wären das
wäre dann kaum auszumachen wir könnten
diese apokalyptischen einschlag kaum
ausweichen dieses szenario stellten die
paläontologen david emm raub und
invasion der kosten von der university
of chicago in den usa 184 auf die
untersuchten die verschiedenen phasen
des massensterbens auf der erde und
stellten eine periodizität fest alle 26
millionen jahre kam es zu solchen
katastrophen als ursache machten sie
schließlich meteoritenschauer aus um
postulierten damals ein zwillings objekt
der sonne den zwillings der nemesis der
sich alle weg von 20 millionen jahre den
sonnen system nähert und diesen
meteoritenschauer verursacht er aus der
orten wolke um unser sonnensystem stammt
wo der stern gestein staub und eis
körper durch seine gravitation
herausgelöst hat diese arbeit wurde in
der folge heftig diskutiertes wurden
andere ursachen für das massenaussterben
und das regelmäßige auftreten genug da
aber schlussendlich konnten sich die
forscher und forscherinnen nicht einigen
bis heute aber heute scheint sich das zu
ändern am erst 30 jahre neueste
forschung sprechen dafür dass es
tatsächlich genommen für die nemesis
gibt und der stern hier wirklich
regelmäßig vorbei kommt das ist schon
eine irre vorstellung und auch ein
bisschen spooky dass es tatsächlich ein
weiteres riesiges gestirn geben könnte
neben planet 9 der ja noch gesucht wird
das café zu unserem system dazu gehört
und nur extrem selten auftaucht und dann
auch noch durch schlimme katastrophen
auslöst aber wie kommen die
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
jetzt darauf war der wolf vom harvard
smithsonian center for astrophysics und
steven taylor von der university of
california in berkeley haben sich näher
mit der sternentstehung beschäftigt und
dabei verblüffende festgestellt dafür
haben wir die daten der radioteleskope
des very large array sin
den usa ausgewertet wie stammten aus der
beobachtung der perseus molekül wolke
die wolke ist eine sternen wie gewohnt
zur zeit zahlreiche sterne entstehen die
zum teil nur 500.000 jahre alt sind und
die jüngsten dieser stern babys sind
nahezu alle ausnahmslos doppelsterne nur
ältere sterne treten auch einzeln auf
und jetzt haben die beiden verschiedene
modelle ausprobiert um zu berechnen wie
oft solche doppel sterne entstehen und
jetzt kommt es wieder das einzige modell
das die perseus beobachtung
reproduzieren konnte war eines in dem
alle sterne ursprünglich als
doppelsterne mit weiten entfernung
zwischen den beiden partnern entstehen
sagt sieben zähler
genauso wie sich bei nehmen sind und der
sonne verhalten würde wie diese sterne
sehr weit voneinander entfernt märz 500
astronomische einheiten
das ist die 17-fache entfernung vom
neptun zur sonne den äußersten bekannten
planeten unseres sonnensystems und zitat
wahrscheinlich gab es vor langer zeit
wirklich eine nemesis mein fehler
allerdings muss diese these jetzt mit
anderen sternen wiegen bestätigt werden
taylor und sah dabei bin aber
zuversichtlich dass ihre these bestätigt
wird dann haben wir hier aber wirklich
weh zu tun wo ist nemesis ist dann die
frage wie bereiten wir uns auf einen
deutsch dramatischen meteoritenschauer
vor wie geben wir das wissen an
möglicherweise in einigen millionen
jahren hier lebende nachkommen weiter
und so weiter und so fort
aber es gibt einen lichtblick nicht
immer hat laut dieser these nemesis das
massenaussterben ausgelöst zwei mal ist
es ausgefallener sorgt vielleicht kommt
nemesis der ortsmitte nicht immer so nah
dass der stern dieses bombardement nicht
ich bin wirklich wahnsinnig spannend wir
haben also einen neuen himmelskörper der
wahrscheinlich existiert und zu unserem
sonnensystem zumindest mittelbar gehört
und wen wir jetzt suchen die nähe des
suche falls es etwas neues dazu gibt es
natürlich hier wenn er zu diesem thema
auch in der zukunft nicht verpassen
wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den auf die
blogger denn nur dann bekommt ihr auch
eine benachrichtigung wenn ein neues
video online geht hier geht es weiter
mit dem mysteriösen planeten 9 und der
suche danach einfach draufklicken und
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran